so Iran uh obviously it's been a mess
if you've seen some of the videos we
talked about it I think on the last
podcast on what is taking place is there
place there at a reaction video I did to
it but a few things that people need to
know what he run you know everybody
lives their lives and does their own
thing but sometimes when you actually
see what is really going on and what the
climate in Iran is you know a lot of
people left right center it doesn't
matter what it is there are certain
things that we all agree on when it
comes down to men and women okay the
basic basic things that we all agree on
where everybody should be treated
equally when it comes down to voting
marriage divorce you know all that stuff
but let me just give you some stats
folks this is Iran and you tell me how
you feel about this would you be okay
living in a country that accepted this
at age seven girls in Iran are forced to
wear headscarves to attend elementary
school they can't go to school if they
don't comply according to the Islamic
law if you kill someone you have to pay
some sort of atonement blood money to
the family of the victim you ready for
this one the money you have to pay for
killing a woman is half the money you
have to pay for a man okay that is in
Iran women don't have the right to
divorce their husbands they're basically
stuck in their marriages as long as
possible their husbands want them to be
men have the rights to divorce their
wives whenever they want being gay queer
is illegal the punishment for death for
being gay in Iran is death penalty
having a dog is illegal you can't take
your dog out for a walk the police will
can literally take away your dog and
kill it if they want to that's true you
see I wonder what they do too I think if
they have a cat they kill the dog and
the cat and the owner is what they do
everybody goes down the cat is like you
gotta be careful with that one they
throw stupid puberty ceremony for us
when they turn nine they brainwash girls
with this is a day you turn into a woman
at nine years old they make us wear
chador similar to Abaya on that day and
force us to say Islamic prayers and
Iranian man is allowed to have four
wives uh at the same time Iranian women
should be stoned thrown Stones until
death if they are proven to have
committed infidelity partying is illegal
dancing is illegal singing is illegal
for women women are not allowed to play
musical instruments and public satellite
TV is illegal you can't go to the beach
and sunbathe and swim with your entire
family because it's illegal young girls
are forced into marriages with men they
barely know girls as young as nine years
old are forced into these marriages does
this sound like a place you want to live
in does this sound like a place now
here's the thing though this is the part
yesterday I was doing a podcast with
this guy David a Jewish guy very
interesting podcast he didn't like what
Tate stood for so he's got a big
following on Twitter we did a podcast
together it was very entertaining and
you know I said to him I said here's the
part on why I love everything be in
public because ideas good or bad social
media makes people listen to what I just
read right now and some of you may have
chills all over your body and you're
saying that's unfreaking believable that
is horrible and then the world gets to
say these are horrible ideas and Common
Sense eventually wins a conservative
women
prime minister of Italy who's one of the
top socialist countries in the world do
you remember the covet breakout in Italy
just two and a half years ago what they
did with the shutdown the country said
we don't want this yeah you're seen in
Iran women are out there marching
protesting I got calls yesterday I'm
talking trying to do an interview with
the shots on Reza palavi we're talking
to Darius Googoosh we're talking to all
these guys to see if we can put on a
concert to support what Iran I'm talking
to all these different musicians these
people that are calling me big name
celebrities in the Iranian community
people are saying we're sick of it
because bad ideas get exposed and that's
exactly what's happened in Iran today
which is a great thing by the way Elon
Musk did activate starlink for Iran
which I think if you ask me all these
you know the other day uh Joe Biden gave
a human humanitarian I think uh award to
uh Elton John yeah
and I'm sitting there saying when are
you guys going to give a Nobel Prize to
Elon Musk I'm going to keep saying that
until these guys realize you're
activating starting to give free
internet access to places like Iran
where we can see exactly what's going on
and people can make a decision because
the government it's a sad situation what
are your thoughts being from there as
well the first thing just on the Elon
Musk because the government shut down
the internet right
yes and you guys will feel me the first
thing when I saw this past especially
because my mom and dad are from Iran the
first thing I don't know why it jumped
to it is is the the people here
especially some of these hardcore
feminist women I go they don't they
don't know nothing about this right they
complain about how horrible this place
is but think about it as a woman in the
United States you can go to college you
could have 90 cats nobody's gonna say
[ __ ] you could sleep with everybody on
the team you could get out become a CEO
you could do whatever you could go on
the streets March make up with the girl
take her clothes off burn the flag say
hashtag kill all men nothing happens
this poor girl her hat was crooked and
the morality police they have [ __ ]
morality police sorry for my language
beat her to death okay so anytime I hear
anybody complain especially those
feminists about this place because Pat
you nailed it they don't know those who
they don't they don't know those stats
and to be honest you they don't give a
[ __ ] they don't care so some from now on
I'm not saying this to those people that
are just so anti-america take a time out
take a step back look what's going on
nobody knows bro you can't have a dog
that's like the least one at all you
can't have it's illegal to have a dog
you're you're forcing people to wear
kids on their heads you know I mean like
it's a perspective nobody knows nobody
cares great uh great perspective by
Vinnie and I appreciate that I remember
when remember when Pharrell uh song came
out so I'm happy yeah and then there's a
group of people in Iran that just wanted
to be happy and sing the song
we never heard from them again ever
again they just wanted to be happy I
think to to your point about
um Elon Musk and starlink in the Nobel
Peace Prize
look for Millennia what were the three
basic necessities that everyone needed
to survive Food Water Shelter okay and
then over the last couple hundred years
that TR that that went to Food Water
Shelter money and resources right so it
went from three to four now today Food
Water Shelter money internet access how
many people are going to survive around
the world without internet access
internet access I mean the one thing
people in Iran will need the one thing
Elon Musk is bringing to the table with
starlink is freaking internet so they
can shine a light on what's happening
there without it being basically in the
dark because like you said nobody knows
this kind of stuff no nine-year-old
stuff this seven-year-old stuff no
dancing no being happy [ __ ] can't
even have a dog no this is what the
moolahs are doing in Iran yeah you know
there's an interesting parallel to him
here though you know listening to this
because there is a thirst for Freedom
around the world you know you're talking
about Iran we can talk about Italy
there's a thirst for Freedom popping up
except here except the land of the free
what is happening here where is the
thirst for Freedom here what I see in
the United States is the opposite what I
see is a spoiled privileged complacent
population and you know it's interesting
you talk about women's rights over there
what Vinnie was saying is true you're
talking about re this is what real
discrimination looks like thank you this
is active discrimination when you talk
about women's rights in the United
States right now you know what you talk
about allowing women to do late-term
abortions on babies so we who's lost
here we are we are lost we are a society
that we are supposed to be the land of
the free we are supposed to be what
other places look to and say we want to
do that what are we doing we have a
bunch of people in this country and it's
a large segment of the population that
is very comfortable with being
subservient to Authority at all costs
Authority tells you to lock down your
business and you're like okay Authority
tells you to put a mask on your kid and
send them to school even though there's
no data to support it okay Authority
tells you to get a mandatory injection
that your doctor told you is not good
for you okay we just watched that unfold
for two years so there is something
wrong here and and we have to we have to
really address that because you can talk
about what's going on around the world
everyone says oh America is a beacon of
Liberty you can't even point to the
military anymore you used to be able to
point to the U.S military and say the
U.S military has one Mission they have
one Mission they have one passion no
it's a bunch of people watching woke
videos that look like they were built
for small children it looks like Blue's
Clues you've got the military sitting
and watching Blue's Clues for the woke
yep so this is a huge problem and until
we face it within ourselves you know
what's going to happen you're going to
wind up seeing Freedom fights in other
countries that are successful where they
turn around and they say these policies
of the last 20 years we don't want that
anymore and you're going to have America
going backward big time where you have
all of these big government Advocates
squashing freedom and authoritarians are
going to rise right to the top so what
happens then and that's the huge
parallel I see because I'm so tired
honestly of people saying America you
know America land in the free where
where is the freedom show me who those
Freedom Fighters are republicans in
Congress who sat on their asses for the
last two years while businesses were
shut down and said [ __ ] about it
where is it show me where those Freedom
Fighters are here because we can't be a
beacon for anybody unless we're doing it
ourselves and we're not doing it so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]